there's a little bit of my comedy back
story that is that I have to tell which
was a lot of people that my age
filtered through your show either as
like cast you know through UCB or
internships and I did not but I really
tried my damnedest and I wound up
getting an interview uh with Cecile is
that was that did she run interns I
think she did for a while it's been a
while before my time but uh Cecilia uh
yeah here's our casting director Nicole
savini was uh and Cecilia plava also
play at camel toe Annie yeah
a character named camel toe Annie who
had her own dance and a song and she
would run out and great great but she
was great at her job and then we were
like are you going to be willing to put
on this prosthetic and really tight
pants you don't need me to describe what
camel toe would live in the name sure
yeah yeah I think it is and anyway she
would run out and do this wild uh hip
grinding dance while the song camel toe
and it would play and uh so shout out to
her because she was great I think I
interviewed with her for an internship
yeah and uh because I had when I was a
sophomore in college I cold called NBC
Human Resources I literally called I I
called information and got NBC and I
said can I have human resources and then
and then I said I'm looking for an
internship and they said well when's
your spring break can you come in for an
interview and I came to 30 Rock
literally from a cold call I got into 30
Rock for an internship for a for an
interview and they said okay well you
seem like a nice kid uh where do you
want to work and I said Conan O'Brien or
Saturday Night Live I want to work
Saturday Night Live well wait a minute
you said Conan O'Brien yeah but they
judged it yeah why'd you have to edit it
okay make sure uh girl that you cut out
this certain life yeah right um no but
they said you can't they said well the
Saturday Night Live internships are only
you know fall and spring semesters so
which one of those can you do and I said
I can't what are you [ __ ] kidding me
I go to school I can't right in Ohio I
can't go to if that language that's
probably what you did yeah and then I
was very angry and and then so I said
well what else can I do they said well
Conan is year round so you could do that
in the summer and I said yes that'd be
amazing and I went she sent me right
down to interview with Cecilia had a
great chat and then I went back up and
they said well while you're here why
don't we send you some other places so I
went down to channel four which was on
your floor right across the hall yeah
wnbc which is the the New York City
local NBC affiliate it
Flagship station
I interview there in their press and
publicity Department
and that and and and the The woman there
says well this I feels like we got a
great fit you you got the you got the
job
and I was like uh oh okay great amazing
um but I also had this little pit in my
stomach like I think my interview with
with late night went well I will just I
don't know I guess I have to take this
so I went back to school like a week
later Cecilia calls me on my dorm phone
and she's like hey great news we we'd
love to bring in for the summer and I
was like oh and I had this like Crisis
and I thought
if I turn my back on wnbc press and
publicity
it that will follow me through Show
Business forever it would have and I
can't I don't want Chuck
exactly and and and so I I told Cecilia
that I had already accepted this
internship at like literally down the
hall and that I had to just do it I had
to stick it out yeah and so I did and I
and I would walk past your studio every
day just like
so sad and I'd say hi to Cecilia and she
would like she let me into some tapings
oh good I remember
um seeing uh an amazing sketch uh they
actually it's I would love to retell it
but it was I feel like it's too long but
it was about a a chef it was about one
of your guests was an author who had a
book but also when he was scared he
would smell ham
or something like that and that's my
comedy sensibility America and so he's
doing this interview with you and at
some point at some point that's why I'm
here doing a podcast he starts he starts
getting really scared during the
interview and it looks like a real
interview like you guys are doing are
playing it super straight and he starts
getting really really scared and he's
like well he's like and you're like
what's going on he's like I I just I
just I smell ham I'm really scared and
then he runs off to the side of the
stage and pulls a curtain and there's
just a guy cooking a giant ham yeah and
he's like oh thank God it was just an
actual ham instead of my fear reflex
smell of ham or some just bizarre and it
was more confirmation that this was
genius and I was in the wrong place
it all worked out fine and I love to say
my abs I was absolutely convinced that
if I didn't I've said this many times
before but in the in in 1986 I was
convinced if I don't get a job with
David Letterman
um as a writer performer then I will
never ever ever amount to anything that
is my only path and I got real close
didn't get it
and uh but when I look at everything
that's happened in my career I realized
if I had gotten that I never would have
gotten gone to SNL yeah met Lauren
Lauren wouldn't have seen something in
me and said hey you know maybe he could
take over for a letterman no one else
would have done that yeah I I still I've
told Lauren I still think it was a
mistake uh but thank God and so it's
that's a message I try and tell a lot of
young people out there is you are
convinced that there is a way yeah and
they're in an infinite number of ways
yeah and you're it's always going to be
different than what you thought and this
was hard for me to understand too but I
feel like you get the jobs you're ready
for yes and you and and when you don't
get the job it it's not because you're
not capable of it eventually but but for
some reason you probably weren't ready
for it